[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody I'm currently pushing with
a different point of my voice because if
I don't I kind of sound weird that
seemed like my voice is going how you
livin how you doing how you feeling how
you're moving and you're grooving that
you do with it so I had a busy week last
week me and ingmar were out at Lake
Tahoe for two days where we got a bunch
of cool interviews which we're gonna be
having coming out this week we're gonna
have Travis Kelce and Rob Riggle coming
out later this week and then a bunch of
other guys we I caught up with Vrabel I
caught up with Case Keenum
I did see Sims and me and Sims got to
hang out for you know a few hours had
some tequila fortunately no daddy cigars
it was it was a business trip was a work
trip he misses you guys he misses the
33% and we did agree to a possible home
and home so I might go up and do his pod
he may come down and do this pod so I
don't we don't have an official date on
that but he was he was pumped about it
he's the man he's still kicking ass and
he's feeling great so I was there for
two days and then I went to Vegas
bleacher report had an event called the
jump off and I was doing for four hours
a dunk contest three on three and my
voice got destroyed because when you're
doing a dunk contest and you're going
Shana go you're gonna lose your voice so
that's what happened we are gonna have
Justin Pugh on today's podcast and it's
kind of perfect because the baton
ratings just came down and that's all
people are talking about so we're gonna
do a lot of guests the Madden ratings
with Pugh we're gonna talk about Kyler
Murray and have we already seen the
moments in camp that make his eyes pop
and then just kind of talk about life in
the NFL you guys have heard pew pew was
actually the first guests we had when
this became just the left go show and
Sims was gone so it's good to check in
with my good buddy old friend
but real reason I'm doing an intro right
now is because I want to get to the
second commercial break faster so that I
don't like when you guys hit me up and
say hey that commercial hit right after
you asked a question I'm trying to get
out of the way so how about this we're
gonna go to commercial and on the other
side justin pew be right back alright
let's go
the voice is back we got the commercial
all the way and just a viewers in the
building pleasure
do you realize you were like the first
guest I had post Sims I do and I wanted
to make a comment the music is so you
thank you before I felt like I had to
come in like you have like a little swab
about yeah I have like a little I'm not
gonna gas you up too much but like when
I was sober exams I felt I had to wear a
suit you know we're all business yes
the thing with and I just saw Sims us
last weekend so it's okay how's he doing
he's good man
he's Sims is so football all the time
and I've realized as I've done more
interviews without him I'm like man I
like to talk about a lot of [ __ ] so I
it's to let me kind of go in some weird
directions yeah he was talking about
some different things though I mean
you're you were you open him up a little
bit well the beautiful thing about Sims
is he that's his obsession bro like he
eats and lives and breathes it and so
when people like [ __ ] on him online
about not knowing football I go if he
doesn't know if I bother nobody knows
football because that's all he [ __ ]
cares about I'm also like let's go play
some blackjack drink some tequila get a
little crazy talk about real estate all
that stuff so you thought you thought
when you propose to someone that you got
a ring too I thought maybe there's like
there there has to be some outward
showing that Amon I'm taking off the
market hey ladies yes when I put my
floral suit on and I'm walking the red
carpet you like hey don't be taking
pictures for anything else what you
think about the jacket that I liked it
I've done a few things it's a big guy
see you're not you're right you're right
it's tough to pull off some of the
colors I kind of go with this subtle
things so my fiancee so Pew did not
realize that was not I was engaged
because he didn't see a ring my fiancee
agrees with you she believes that men
should have engagement rings too and
that I should wear it so that the exact
same reason women don't come up to me
she thinks it should be more official
because when you walk out I'm sure you
had security escort you right to it it's
really hard no the true the true thing
is is that like I mean I guess unless
you're looking for it I don't know NFL
players it must be interesting women
just walk up to like do you watch guys
on your team and it's just nuts
yeah yeah yes I'm sure I'm not gonna say
Hugh but I'm sure Odell was crazy I can
only imagine what he's gone through hell
yeah I'm sure in Cleveland will be a
little bit different I would the
Cleveland six isn't the same as in New
York six
I know I've never been so I'm so like in
Arizona Arizona it's like what's the
party scene like in Arizona oh it's it's
it's it's very different from New York
but it has the same level of craziness
yeah I mean you've heard the stories of
the Arizona State that's what I've heard
and you know I was downtown area in Old
Town Scottsdale my girlfriend didn't
move out there with me yet as soon as
she gets out and goes downtown she goes
you're not going down there I said yes
ma'am I just got it I got back and I
walked right back in the house have you
killed any scorpions since the last time
we talked
I've killed multiple scorpion seis I go
out with a black light my girlfriend
really is the biggest murderer and she's
into it I've killed a snake since I've
seen you last problem did I kill this
thing when I saw you last I think you
did yeah so I've got one snake under my
belt they don't come around anymore the
scorpions you got with the black light
and a hammer and you take them out all
right so I want to get right into this
madden ratings have started coming out
have you seen your mat and rating yet I
haven't I want to preface this with you
know I've haven't finished the last two
season so I know madam probably is
coming after me what was the highest
matter rating you've had
I don't know I'm gonna I have no idea I
think I was I was the highest rated
giant soul I'm in for a little while so
let me ask you this question when you
first got to the league what is it like
to see yourself and Madden
I don't play Madden as much any okay
since I got into the NFL when I was in
college yeah
time I was so pumped and then when
Madden start [ __ ] on you you're just
like [ __ ] those guys so there's a lot of
people saying [ __ ] those guys right now
because Madden changed their ratings a
little bit they created these tears
elite near elite quality low level
starter back up low level back up and
what they did was they wanted the elite
guys to be super elite like they were
like we have too many guys that are 95
and more yeah so they kind of lowered a
lot of people I don't hate that I think
it makes sense because I'm a starter in
the NFL and I go to any team I'm
starting in the NFL right so I mean they
could put me anywhere they want to put
me I'm Priya low level starters I'm a
realist
so aerialist let me just give you a
perspective of the guys they dropped
Aaron Rodgers went down to a 90 and he's
a 99 right something like that Alvin
Kamara is furious he's at an 89 I agree
with Elvin you know the hell is alvin
kamara buddy
give me your list of your top three
running back to the enemy elite I want
to do yours and then I want to kind of
guess because I think it's interesting
like the reason that I think this is
important is when I was growing up PFF
did not exist yes there was no way to
really know whether a certain position
was good especially a position like
yours because there's a lot of people
out there that are either gonna look at
a PFF or they're gonna look at Madden to
decide Oh Justin pews actually good and
I think it really impacts defensive
players because at least with offense
there's fantasy guys so like if you
perform well in fantasy everyone's gonna
know you're good guys know the
third-string running back from the
Chargers because they know Austin Eckler
because he filled is good but a nose
tackle like I grew up knowing that
Patrick sir tan and Sam Madison were
good corners because they were 97's and
Madden yeah all hundred percent like I
knew I knew that that one linebacker was
solely because of Madden and you knew
Derrick Johnson from the Chiefs we ran
afford one run out of Texas so you won
them on your team yeah because the speed
was there a hundred percent so guess my
rating is well what do you think your
overall Madden rating is Justin pew of
the Arizona
well I'm a starter in the NFL I have to
be in the upper I had to be I if they
didn't put me in the 70s I got at least
Bo I think I'm a low 70 got 72 Justin
Pugh madden rated you a 73 oh my I love
him I'm just going to buy the game so
you're happy with a 73
well we're realist I'm a realist I'm not
an idiot some of these guys he's not
calling you I'm not calling anyone but
some of the guys are unrealistic about
who they are as a player I know I'm one
of the best guards in the NFL yeah I've
gotten hurt the past two years so how
can I say that when I haven't gone out
there and done that all right so I have
a few categories here that I want you to
guess the categories what do you think
your awareness is well based off what
I've just said how where I am of my
situation I bet I at least should be in
the 90s when it comes to my wares but I
know I'm probably an 86 you're a 79
awareness okay I think I should be in
the 80 cents this is one that's sort of
really testing your manhood what do you
think you are in strength you know what
when I went to Syracuse they called me
puny because I wasn't very strong so
whatever they gave me I actually think
is better than where I'm at what do you
think they gave you what do you think
you you are in that and strength and
84-88 okay they put some muscles on you
pass now I am you know now I got ya pass
blocking and run blocking they should
have made me a better pass blocker than
run block they did perfect
73 pass block 71 run block okay and what
do you think your stamina is lime in
turn are getting discredited here all
the time but as I should have one of the
best stat Amma's for the offensive line
yeah our staff is down I made it up
doesn't matter word it's boards end it's
gonna be 64 90 - oh really
92 stamina I'm thinking mad and we try
to discredit us and say the receivers
could run further know how the Camaro's
of this world can just run all day I
love it nice I love that but that's
really where I'm at
I don't know who's following me around
that seemed like I can go so you like
these right now it's just I know I'm
better than it
73 I want to know what the left guards
are at who's the best left gardening all
right let's check it out I'm gonna go to
position left guard let's go to over can
you go over all garden yes let me see
so Zack Martin should be I can do left
guard and right guard put them all
together put them all together filter
okay who this is great and I want
overall I was organizing my throw power
over all who's the number one guard in
the NFL Zack Martin correct according to
that number to door to know who is the
number two garden it's a right guard
it's a right guard jeez now I'm starting
to lose can you give me a conference uh
AFC AFC I really never did that Marshall
yonder from the ball he was number three
hmm number two is David de Castro David
de Castro yeah Gruber forest Brandon
Brooks Brandon Brooks number five is
Kevin's idler Kevin's and he's there all
these are all right guards they are all
right card number one the number one
left guard is in six that's a lemur pet
my agent reps him just got him really
nine dollars a year so shout out the Ali
plated Hobart division three College Wow
so Ali I'm trying to figure out their
ratings but and then you got quit Nelson
down there dude you're really low in
this list that's alright where they go
sort by money earn like dollar bills I
can't do that
okay alright so I know if I had that
what do you think Kyler Murray's speed
is your teammate Kyler Murray what's P
gotta be in the 90s I mean because he
beat we have a kid on our team from
UMass yes Andy Isabella is Adela is
Adela is Adela is a visit is about
Isabella bro I think it's is Adela hindi
is Bella Bella it's Bella so you've been
calling your teammate by the wrong name
I haven't talked to him once he's very
scary when he comes in he hasn't in say
a lot really
every time I he walks by I'm like when I
was in high school and you have like the
one freshman that gets caught up to
varsity in the jerseys too big for him
yeah that's what Isabel Isabel really
that's Andy Isabella sorry Andy well
what I had
in here we were talking about like his
first day in prison which is somehow
that go he was he just said he got
brought in during lunch which is the
worst time because like everyone's in
there and like you kind of get marched
in and I'm not equate again Turing an
NFL locker room to entering prison
because I don't want to make light of
prison but I'm curious when like Annie
Isabella walks in do you think there's
any part of his like I should punch
Darnell Dockett in the head or I should
punch just that is you are the baddest
man in Walker have you ever seen anyone
enter an NFL locker room with that
mindset like I'm gonna prove myself
right away yeah there yeah hundred
percent I mean some rookies come in and
they like fall into the role I'm a young
guy let me hear let me listen let me you
know do what I'm supposed to do yeah
then you have guys that come in and no
one's telling me any different and I've
seen both ends of the spectrum right so
Isabella's a 95 speed so he had collars
a 97 Kyler's a 91 yeah well I mean they
clearly and watch them race so Kyler can
beat him in a race I think they did race
yeah they're beat him yeah no Isabella
kind of look like he was slowing down a
little bit did he I don't know if he's
give me any 90 what the events have ends
are 90s oh all right let me do this
anyone catch Kyler is the question oh
how about we just let's talk real
football first a with Kyler okay cuz I'm
adding readies they're not real you're
saying Madden ratings are trivial I
think I think what you are though
bringing up as an interesting point is
how they stack up against each other I'm
not really curious about what your speed
is but if they think that Kyler Marie is
slower than Andy Isabela but we have
proof that Andy Isabela is I'm checking
the name I you you where you at right
now
I've been trying to talk to Justin pew
for the last five minutes but in his
eyes I could tell all he's been thinking
about is how to correctly say his
teammates last is it is Isabella I'm
looking at it I got to follow him now
would you like to follow him before this
would you like to apologize yeah sorry
Andy actually I'm not sorry you're not
no you should make me learn should have
asserted himself so you they haven't
done when does like the rookie singing
and all that stuff at the training camp
we are works have already like done a
few things they've gotten
you know they got in food for us nothing
crazy yeah this isn't a whole this is a
1994 cousin Miami Dolphins circa 2000
yeah 11 whenever that but so they've
done some food and all that stuff
Kyler Murray have we seen a moment yet
where you guys all looked at each other
and went oh [ __ ] have we had one of
those yet yeah I mean the thing about
Kyler I've said this since he got there
he came in and I don't know if we told
him we were taking him like seven months
prior to but like he the kid had the
offense down he had great demeanor about
him I said the same thing about Josh
Rose I still believe Josh Rosen is gonna
be a great yeah a communal
josh is a great guy I remember you told
me you said Josh would just come into
the huddle and have a lot of confidence
yeah and that was that's when I was like
oh I kind of I can see the teammates
believe in Josh Rosen yeah Kyler had
that to 100% and I think that Kyler came
in the fact that he knew his stuff
because we're all did he knew it I made
it a whoa big offseason when they were
like Kyler knows the offense better than
most of the was that true well think
about this we went we were only there
like a month before Kyler got there so
we're all learning at the same pace
really I mean a new offense everyone
gets to start at square one and he came
in and he did a lot of good things he
brought us doughnuts
he brought us breakfast sandwiches so he
knew he knew how I said you guys are so
very simple very simple and the things
he can do athletically not many guys can
do I mean I think about Odell was like
the first person that comes to mind and
like you see things and you just like
everyone just stops and you'll watch how
how he throws the ball do you is there a
play that comes to mind from what you've
seen of him so far where you guys all
stopped I think I wanna be taken to the
island I've probably blocked for two of
the not very mobile quarterbacks like
Eli never runs and joyously I actually
ruined Eli's longest run of his career
with a face mask I like hit someone in
the face as they're running away
ruined it so Eli I'm also sorry I'm a
little apologies I'm just doling out
here and then Sam Bradford last year and
and Josh was Britt was actually probably
the most mobile Wow and then I get Kyler
Murray who's probably if he wanted to
because one of the most mobile
quarterbacks in the history of the game
yep there
Vick that's what everyone's saying but
that's not what real I think the first
play we did you know when a read option
or something he kept it and like he just
took off and no I was like that people
do that in the NFL I've never seen a
quarterback you so now the defense has
to account for him you know you sold
Lamar Jackson doing this yeah
Russell Wilson rarely real sure does it
Roger sometimes will do it just to keep
people honest because Rogers can get out
and get after it but just to have that
that option is something that I've never
experienced so that was big for me for
me perfect as you're looking through
Cliff's playbook and you're kind of
running through the plays how much is
the threat of him running a part of that
playbook even if it's like the read
option or something like that I think
you have to use your assets whatever you
have and whenever you have we also had
David Johnson well but I mean like are
there a lot of plays in there that
you've never even seen before where a
lot of it's like we're either stretching
out a defense with Kailah or something
like that
for me it's a very new offense because
I'm coming from pro style Eli Manning
we're not back we throw it a thousand
times a game we run it three times yeah
and so now it's definitely a different a
different feel so I'm excited about I'm
gonna keep learning more about it and I
think the offense will morph into
whatever it's going to be or based on
what we do well and what collar does
well and how he yeah he likes to operate
Kyler's in the huddle what's it like so
far he's got this Texas accent that he
like tell him we got a pronounced in it
we got to pronunciate things like we got
I got to hear you say it so we're
getting him to speak up a little bit
more that's all I mean that's that's
something that comes with just I think
in the pro style and coward I don't even
know if he was in a huddle right exactly
so that's got to be new for him my thing
is and I I learned this through I think
a lot of people learn this from hot
takes on young players if you're gonna
judge a young guy in his first rookie
camp or his training camp like I
remember I saw Terry Rozier at summer
league when the Celtics took him at 17
and everyone's like why did you take him
so high and he was awful and people
wrote him off and now he just got 15
million from Charlotte but to write off
any professional athlete when you're 20
years old or something like that is
insane so that's why anything that could
come out now like if if Tyler and
training camp overthrows some guy
there will be people that are gonna
write them off and never watch another
snap of them until the regular season oh
yeah his madding accuracy yeah but
that's why that's why if there was any
even if like oh he's not as vocal as
maybe he needs to be in the huddle well
yeah cause he just [ __ ] got there
it's okay yeah I mean if I could take
who I was as a rookie and Who I am now
huh it's night and day
how different is it it's crazy I mean I
don't I don't go out as much I'm out in
New York so there's not as many
temptations if you will I'm I'm in a
relationship so obviously that's more
hanging out watch 20 what now 28 going
on 29 how what how well do you feel in
the locker room now oh oh my god I got a
great story there's 28 years old
people are people if you were not in the
NFL people would say you got your whole
life that yeah but what is it actually
like it's a 28 year old all right we we
drafted this kid from Boston College
Zach Allen got that name right it's
pronounced Zach oh is it so he comes in
the locker room he goes I was in eighth
grade when you got drafted to the Giants
that's a [ __ ] you get out then I
dumped him on his head and practices
head don't call him and don't ever say
some [ __ ] like that to me again like
eighth grade so I I look at Larry I said
Larry he just made me feel I can't
imagine what you feel right now
he wasn't even conceived yet whenever it
was a rookie no but that's
I mean 28 years old you got people
coming up to you and saying I was in
eighth grade hey I was on there madden
team in eighth grade how is that
possible I I'm not a mathematician here
but eighth grade now he's in the NFL
like that 10 11 12 four years of college
so eight how many years have you been
the NF seven I don't know think he's
bullshitting me right be worried maybe
he was going into ninth and he left me I
don't know we graduated earlier some
safe grade to me is it like when you
when a young guy comes in how hard is it
to not go hey men keep her in the
playbook focus because I feel like you
you guys also become old so quickly
about like trying to help guys get
through all the [ __ ] but you also
don't want to be like the old head in
the locker room that is like telling
people to like straight like because you
also want to have fun to talk to
Sheridan and Ty yeah there's definitely
a fine line I will never tell a guy not
to have fun cuz I still have fun you
know I still have to get ass with my
buddies and go have a good time but I
also tell the rooks like hey look when
it comes to money like like we're
talking about yes appreciation
depreciating assets we don't need three
cars
we don't need rent your mom the house
that of her dream don't buy it for yet
until you get to that second contract so
I feel an obligation to step in because
we do have such an epidemic with our
players going broke that when it comes
to finances I don't care if I come off
as a dad I come on yes that's all I want
guys to be able to take care of
themselves and not have to I've had guys
I can't even count on one hand this year
that have hit me up and have asked for
Ashley things chance for help did you do
any better
by is when you were a rookie or young
bad buys more like more like anything
stupid you're like what high price
because the more you talk about this the
better it's it's great for NFL players
but it's also good for like a random
like my 33 percent that listens to this
because all of us make dumb decisions
like I was just in Vegas okay I've made
a lot of dumb decisions yeah hun craps
is not a smart decision you get a taste
and you go oh this could be my future
how quick money I got yeah I'm just
drawing up my resignation letter in my
head right now because I'm winning the
lottery tonight if I do this every day
so what were what were some of the
things that you did early on there I
bought a car right away which I probably
wouldn't have done but I always wanted
to Range Rover so I got the all black
blacked out or black you still haven't
it out I sold it and that's when I
realized I'll never buy another car and
let's gonna keep it for my entire night
I'll rent one I'm so that was I don't
think it was a dumb purchase it was just
a I openin like hey maybe you don't need
a nicest it's been interesting to watch
the social media police now I feel like
this offseason we're because a lot more
people are sharing it we're seeing all
the rookies buying houses and cars for
their moms and now the comments are what
a dump I don't buy cars that's so stupid
like it's actually in a weird way I want
to get angry at these fans because I
want to go if you could buy your mom a
car
you would be you would feel like a hero
oh yeah don't don't come out here and
shame these [ __ ] for by their
moms I've learned much rather than be
buying their moms a car then do what I
did my rookie year
I didn't buy my mom anything I mean you
know if she wanted help with something
I'd help her but I went Alan Price pen
wit I know I did way too much money just
going out and living the life in New
York going to a club I have eight best
friends we all have a tattoo yeah
there's an eight it looks like a Google
G and affinity sign whatever the few
crew Eli Manning use across the Infinity
Bros what are you in the infinity bro
there show omerta yeah nice and so you
guys would go out and you're yeah and
you know if we want to go to a club and
they're not letting us in you put the
credit card down say whatever you got to
charge it we're doing it yeah I would go
to Atlantic City where when I was
younger they would never let us into any
of the bars right it was anything you
know living the lifestyle now I look
back if I could just save that money and
put it away and just if I could just go
to every Brook and say instead of doing
what I did by your mom the car I think
the house is such a big purchase that
you should wait I got I did end up
buying my mom a house after I got my
second deal yes but I think it's it's
one of those things where you wait to do
it in till the timings right make sure
you're taking care of yourself first
immediate issues take care of if health
whatever tell me if this is accurate I
think the hardest part about giving an
NFL player advice is talking about how
small your career could be to a player
that police he's gonna live forever yeah
because if I was an NFL player I go oh
I'm getting a third contract I'm
definitely getting a second contract
like I can say this to you because you
got a second contract but most of these
guys are not gonna get a second contract
but to look an NFL player in the face
and go this might be the only contract
you get Alfred Morris hasn't made six
million dollars in his whole [ __ ]
career Alfred [ __ ] Morris like that's
got to be the hardest part as a
financial advisor because if I was a
player I would be I would take offense
to that I'm not gonna be that percentage
I'm never gonna die and to me like
that's gonna be the hardest part about
having financial conversations with
players and that's why I don't feel bad
about it because I've seen it I can say
to a guy look I've seen starting
receivers go out and get her
never see another contract I've seen
second or second round third round
fourth round picks never see the field
yes when I was with the Giants like none
of our draft picks made it to a second
contract like no one was even around
after like two years all the guys were
gone right so I've seen the the average
career which is two and a half years you
don't even get pension you don't get
401k unless you get three years and
three games really the average player
doesn't even get any benefits Wow so
because three years and three games is a
is a very sizable career yeah in the end
of a four year you're on team before you
yeah average player doesn't get that
[ __ ] so my thing is if you know
obviously we're going through
negotiations now and then we're going to
see more and more I just want to get
more things for guys without them even
knowing it right I want to change our we
get paid 17 weeks out of the year so you
going you're your salary divided by 17
is how much that player gets per week so
if you're if you a guy making 17 million
he's getting a million dollar check
every week for just those 17 just those
17 weeks and then you don't get a
paycheck the rest of the year the rest
of the year so it's awesome you get your
money all these guys are like give my
money now I want it now yeah I want to I
want to spread it out
I want a 34 week pay period where you're
not getting as much per week because you
have the guy making a million dollars a
week that's your best play elite players
then you have your barely fringe players
that aren't making at all that are
making 400 grand which don't get mad at
me out there everyone oh that's amazing
money but they don't have value they'll
have a short period of time to make it
great if that guy makes four hundred
thousand for three years then loses his
job has no work experience never did an
internship in college he can't make a
hundred grand
after that per year no so this is what
about what about signing stuff man
there's just like I know that you want
to do some media when you get done I
know a lot of players I want to do media
you're very realistic about how
competitive this [ __ ] is like like I
know people that thought they were gonna
go in the media and then no [ __ ]
calls came because let's be really
honest where who like fox like if you're
gonna call a game there's like six game
six people and
probably already filled you're not
getting on NFL on Fox pregame show
because it's gonna be Strahan and Howie
and Jimmy and don't come to me with well
maybe it'll move on from one yeah
because if they move on from one they're
calling Peyton Manning they're not gonna
call like a long story or a backline
they're not caught on all mens of lime
and either ESPN makes like two or three
hires a year um like maybe and like
there's just not a lot of those jobs and
then you go well what about like
uninterrupted or bleacher report and
it's like maybe it's it what if and
that's why I one of these guys to kind
of do stuff while they're playing and
which is like kind of what you're doing
now but also like start your own [ __ ]
you know what I mean but I never
realized that the paychecks only come
after games all the stories I've ever
heard about getting into your locker and
the paychecks there but I never realized
it didn't come in the other weeks so
these guys also have to be smart during
the rest of the year or else they're
sitting there scratching their neck be
like when's my paycheck coming this one
this is the issue so guys get two weeks
you know get to March April May June no
monies coming in at this point it's
starting to dry up so now they're like
that's why these players are cheap when
I take them out to dinner in March yeah
you got to take them out during the
season if you take them out on a Tuesday
off day and they just got 23 grand
Tuesday's the day to go Tuesday's the
day to take an NFL player out to eat and
that's the issue we run into guys are
getting checks you know you're making
four hundred thousand you know lop off
half in taxes because we're taxes yep so
then you know you pay your Asia and you
pay your whoever else is in that in that
field and then you're left with that
money and you're like wow I still have
12 thousand dollars and they think
they're getting it every week they're
not so that's when they go buy these
houses they go buy these cars because
they're like I'm getting 20,000 a week
this is gonna last forever like you said
and it doesn't week 17 comes along now
I've seen guys take loans like paying
back 40 percent interest on these loans
like wow because people come in there
are sharks out there they're just
waiting for June July to hit and these
guys are struggling for money see what's
interesting about that is I've always
heard the Sharks in terms of you know
come and invest in this or taking
advantage of like you having lump sums
of money and trying to get you to buy
into a private jet or mine
show up they show up on Tuesdays they
show up I said no no but like I would
[ __ ] believe it or run this season
when they know that money's coming in a
hundred percent let me go let me call
him now you called me in June I'm not
ready to write that check draw me during
the season when they Oh what do I want
to do with this money because guys are
thinking about it that's when the sharks
are in the water so when you're when
you're hearing all the CBA talks right
now as someone that is taking meetings
about your financial future and actually
paying attention to it my theory is that
the NFL always tries to float out new
ideas right before a CBA so that you
guys argue for everything other than
money we're gonna play 18 games
scheduled and only have 60 and then you
guys spend all this time arguing against
it and by the way they're like we're
just gonna keep the 50 whatever percent
we have in revenue like how many players
in the NFL do you think are really up to
date about the current CBA discussions
and all that stuff I don't even want to
talk about it at all because then you're
a player rep right yeah I'm an alternate
player rep which is the best kind of rep
to be cuz you're not having to make the
phone calls every day no I still I still
get on the phone call I still want to
know what's going on and I want to be
involved and when I was in New York
exactly Aziz the longer he got me
involved say hey look this is directly
gonna impact your future the guys that
come after his future so this this whole
lockout pasal cba all that it has in
2011 these guys lived through it and we
know it's on the horizon we know 2020 is
right around the corner we know the
owners you have some things that they
want to get accomplished and as a
Players Union we have to we have to band
together we have to be stronger than
ever so I don't I don't even want to get
into because I I might say something I
don't want to socialize you're that
well-versed in it I know what's going on
yeah how about this didn't speak in
generalities just from 2011 all I hear
about from the NFLPA side is that you
guys are more prepared than ever does it
feel that way like is there like kind of
a confidence I wasn't here in 11 I mean
I was just from what you've guarded from
I do see ya and everything when it was
so crazy what was going on then we just
need you know more and more guys you
have 32 billionaires and then you have
you know all the players wherever are I
you're getting 35
or something like that it's it's these
guys are the best at what they do in
their business so that's why we with the
PA have tried to find the best yeah can
to help represent us to help make this a
fair fight
because miiverse Jerry Jones or miiverse
Steven Ross Michael Bidwell is not gonna
go well for me yeah I can you know we
were talking about just trying to come
up with some finance returned yes now
and we struggle these guys made their
living what does FDI a mean okay yeah no
I don't want to get you in trouble and I
also I think the interesting thing with
talking about the CBA with a player is
you don't want to be the player that
speaks for all of the players right now
you know I love our guys so I'm gonna
fight for everything that our guys get
without even knowing it
and I want to fight for the guy that's
all the way at the bottom and the guy
always hop we had to protect the middle
class of the NFL we need the game to be
stronger than ever going forward and I
think we're gonna try to get that
accomplished and we'll see where it goes
I've been saying for three years that I
thought this was gonna end in a lockout
but there were some reports that came
out recently that they're actually
making good progress I would love it if
the NFL could get to a part where kind
of the NBA is where there's a lot of
trust like I was I was flying back from
Vegas and I was sitting next to one of
the pro player personnel people for the
Cavaliers and we were just talking about
different stuff and I'm asking you think
Ben Simmons is gonna get a jump shot all
that stuff but then we were talking
about Adam and and they said the best
part about Adam is our players trust
Adam and that's where I hope the NFL
gets to where it's not we're gonna fight
for what we want it's every contract
they made us an offer that respected us
from the get-go it's not about what can
we take from you guys it's we've we've
talked about it and we think you guys
deserve this that's what I want 100%
imagine if we were in a league where
there wasn't like this big brother
watching over us yes cuz that's what it
feels like Pro with our Commissioner
right now yeah imagine if we could be in
a league where like the NBA like you
said there's so much money the NFL is
the number one sport
yeah revenue wise and in the country
let's let's work together like the more
we can do the better we can be all
together but it's tough everyone has
their hands in the cookie jar
of course so we're gonna see I mean
obviously I've a lot of faith in our
Union we have a lot of smart guys at
playing this lead that are that are
standing up and they're ready to to help
make some changes and hopefully it all
it all works out
oh we were talking we talked about
Isabela before how has he looked so far
like Justin camps and stuff like that
he's the I'm gonna get his name wrong
then I'm gonna say this is probably just
say Bella Isabela yeah you said he's
like the fresh with the tea but how was
he on the field though unbelievable
really yeah yeah you look at him and he
looks like he's you know you're at the
varsity practice and he's the JV kid
jerseys a little too big for him yeah
every time I see him I guess I don't
call him Isabel I just I don't know what
I say to a mountain either one I call
him a bud I think it's bottomed her good
pal we gotta get you a smaller Jersey so
it fits you better yeah but the kid can
make plays I mean really there's a
reason why like he's always catching the
ball everyone's always screaming not his
name I don't know what everyone's
calling him now I think my old line
coach must have been calling him is
Adela and that's why I started cooking I
don't know how what I love it
but because that's the thing is as
something like I know that Isabella was
I'm gonna call Mandy and II was really
loved by like the the draft community as
like a guy that could come in right away
and really be special like in the slot
and stuff like that and so I'm always
curious because he doesn't look
physically imposing but you say and
right now he's making splashes already
for yeah you make pledge like who is it
you know when someone's making plays and
you can obviously tell in a skilled
position who yeah who has and who
doesn't whereas offensive line I feel
like the other teammates don't really
get to see that battle as much but every
time I turn around the kids making a
play or making a catch cliff you were
excited about him when he first got
there you could tell he was cool um does
the quality like what kind of a coach is
he what have you learned already just
being around in the building and all
that stuff he's very laissez-faire like
just go get into your meeting rooms
let's let's let's handle we can control
I'm not gonna hold you guys in team
meetings long I'm not running it you
know I've had coaches before and it's
very like regimented and Tom Coughlin's
it was great all my doing and he would
he would have us you know Abraham
Lincoln was born on today
Martin Luther King this was his holiday
this is what made him so great and why
he was great he would give us these
lessons and it was unbelievable it's a
different approach to yeah oh gee he was
something beautiful about he was he was
just coaching us to be men as well as
football players and cliff comes in and
he's like his his first go around Tucson
or you know obviously was at the college
level but coaching men I think like
Larry and Phil Dawson are like they're
in the same draft like they were all
like right around the same time class
awesome so he's very like let's turn
this thing around we got to worry about
this football thing first wears coffins
like I've won two Super Bowls
so I he's building off of what he's
doing I didn't get to see Coughlin year
one which apparently wasn't very good
all he bought me that adds a lot of
players so cliff done a great job so far
coming in we're getting back to the
football we're getting in there we're
gonna cook we're gonna write this ship
and then you know boat as we go how like
people always say he's cool just the way
he dresses and stuff like like is he
cool like was there a story or something
like that where you're like man this guy
whether it's like a speech that he kind
of gave her like something that kind of
happened it's just overall demeanor like
he's just he gives off a sense of like
this guy just has it whatever whatever
it is and I don't have it I don't have a
specific story right now I'll have one
by the end of the year something he's
done but he's just he's just been great
you know he just has a good rapport with
the players guys respect him and he
knows football how are you by the way
how's your wrist and everything the
hands good the knees good yeah I feel as
good as I've ever felt I mean and then
week one will hit and then we'll see how
you feel then
exactly and that's the thing too I can't
there's nothing I can do differently in
the offseason like I don't nothing I
don't go out nearly as much I don't do
anything but work out and get ready to
go I play I play golf yeah ready to play
football so yeah you can't do anything
about breaking a hand you can't do
anything about ligament in your knee
going so the past two years I put them
behind me I feel better than I am I'm
back at left guard my natural position
now I was with the New York Giants I was
kind of like hey played every position
playing von Miller this week you're
playing right tackle all right Aaron
down are you're going back virgin play
last year I played right guard last year
who'd you have a left that moves your
nightly potty who only a play left and
Mike's an unbelievable
but he only plays left and now you're
gonna go back to lasso I'm pumped to go
back to left guard is it like I in
Madden you can just flip guys around it
doesn't even matter
yeah and we've talked I think before
about how different it is mm-hmm
to say like to be home is is how
exciting is it to be at a position that
you think is natural for you you feel
comfortable you don't have there's no
anxiety about like what ifs like you
feel awkward stepping with a foot a
certain way and doing a certain block
you know it's it's you're not thinking
as much yeah it's a hundred percent
natural in that in that aspect and I
think I've done it enough where I feel
comfortable doing and I've played games
in the NFL right yeah : right guard but
I feel the best at left guard I think
Josh is either joshan or somebody's like
they asked on or TJ lying one of the
packers guards yeah there's a what's it
like switching from left to right and he
was like go home and wipe your ass but
the other hand and see how messy it gets
yeah you still get it done but sometimes
just a little the technique isn't is
that it's not there man I think I I
think there's reason to be excited about
you guys I think you the offensive line
as a whole being healthy David Johnson
being healthy as is he out there doing
stuff right now
yeah that guy's our freak where where
are we at with David Johnson how's he
look compared to the injuries and kind
of a slow start last year yeah I think
well obviously when you're not very good
on the field and you guys are putting up
points and you're down in games you
can't just feed David Jones on the ball
so I think he's obviously gonna be a big
part of our offense
people forget that he's one of the best
running backs in the NFL absolutely
oh who's this guy that almost went for
you know he had the one year what do you
have a thousand of thank you a thousand
both yeah I mean he's in great shape
he's a great guy so I'm looking forward
to him having a big year bouncing back
as well as the entire team all right I
want to see what David Johnson's reading
is yeah he's got to be I bet you he's in
the 80s he's got to be in the 80s David
Johnson is an 87 with a 92 speed they
still put some respect on him I think so
too
Kyler Murray is a 73 what's like the
other court he's the best rated
quarterback or best rider rookie Eli's a
72
I already know that Stafford is a 79 so
they're really just cracking down but
can you believe that
I can't Carson Wentz's an 82 well Carson
Wentz is kind of in the same the injury
to injury thing so so the top-rated
quarterback do you think who do you
think it is Tom Brady
mahomes he's on the cover mahomes is 97
Brady's 96 so you never really think so
if you were starting a team just had one
year to play I would take my own was
over Brady no you're crazy I mean you
had one year and your life depended on
getting a ring was charged in the team
it doesn't matter we it's just your
coaching it yeah then I want my home's
you rather okay because you're saying it
was going to overcome my back I'm not
saying I'm not pulling a Sims and saying
that Brady is made by Belichick I'm just
saying that if I just start a team and
it's like a random assortment of pieces
I believe the piece that is the most
versatile that can do the most stuff is
mahomes okay that's what I think and but
I think you're discrediting what Tom
Brady brings I into the locker I'm
totally just because if you have a bunch
of mismatch of pieces Tom Brady's been
to the promised land
Tommy Wright knows what it takes and I
think I realized that a lot through Nick
Foles who's a 77 by the way but just
hearing the Jaguars talk about Nick
Foles and it was a collossal quote where
he pretty much said the fact that I can
look over and see Nick Foles is there a
Super Bowl MVP gives me a lot of
confidence and I do think that I
underrate that with Tom Brady in terms
of when he goes out there and we had
Ross Tucker in here talking about how he
runs the agility drills still he's still
working on the snap every [ __ ] play
and goat over the center going perfect
snap and it has to be perfect that that
does set the tone but I think also we
discredit the other quarterbacks by by
acting like they don't operate that way
oh yeah a hundred percent but I think
that like the fact that he's able
because Patrick is still so young
yes older guys aren't gonna like if he
like freaks out about something they're
gonna take it more from Tom Brady than
they will with Patrick my home nacho so
if you're trying to get a team in LA but
even if moms won the MVP like when
you're coming off an MVP how much weight
does that hold in a locker room do you
definitely a lot of weight you the MVP
you're the best player in the NFL yeah
but when you're considered as the
greatest of all time ik I'll even take a
Eli Manning and say this if it was Eli
Manning it Patrick my home's giving me
like yelling at me for something yeah
Eli I'm a hundred percent respecting
that more than the patch Mahalo Alice
ISM that's interesting cuz he's been
around he's seen it all he's seen yeah
so he's oh I totally get what you're
saying no I mean like yeah Eli Manning
has been around some of the best guards
in the NFL he's seen that what takes to
win a championship choice from Holmes is
probably the most skilled player in our
league right now I'm him Aaron Rodgers
you could debate this but you're right i
think it's it's like though like i think
about like mad and ratings all that
stuff you can't really factor everything
in because they're not gonna understand
all that like leadership and things it's
it's not saying that my holmes is a bad
leader but undoubtedly andy reid is
probably talking to those guys just as
much whereas a rodgers or a brady or
even an Eli because you got a slide more
to your left there and then you're not
gonna question it because how many
slides has he seen in his career exerts
a paan thousand so I do get it the
culture is is the biggest thing in the
NFL reason I give him a Holmes so much
credit though is I really think the fact
that because his dad was a professional
athlete his ability to communicate with
guys is so good because he's been in
locker rooms for so long now I know that
from a player's perspective you want to
see the winds and the Super Bowls give
you a lot of credo but yeah the rankings
really get crazy at three who do you
think is number three mahomes is one
Brady's - who do you think is three well
you said Rodgers is Roger I know Rogers
and Rogers is four or five sixth drew
Brees true breezes hold on a second he's
on the list hold on what are you what do
you what are you sorting this hold on
because Rivers is three
we're rating in all amount of kids he's
in 94 huh 95 96 94 alright hold on I
need to because breeze has to be on this
I need it the full list okay so number
one is mahomes number two is Brady
number three is that the little and
Philip Rivers oh so he is so you were
right no no I was right where's that you
told me that Bella versus three at
ninety four breeze is number four at 92
luck is number five at 92 Russell Wilson
is 91 and Rodgers is 90 how the hell is
Philip Rivers better than Russell Wilson
or Aaron Rodgers I love Philip Rivers
yeah
but at this point of his career come on
man that's a hint that's a tough one and
we know I'm not crazy right literally
didn't even know if Andrew Luck would
ever be able to play again until last
year and he's rated higher than Aaron
yeah I'm guessing Aaron Rodgers getting
knocked because the injury thing he's
experienced Baker Mayfield is better
than Carson Wentz is it too soon for
that I will just be a flash in the pan
type of reaction to that you know we've
seen what do you know how many games he
played last here'll indeed Dalton is
higher than Matthew Stafford and Jimmy
Garoppolo a grappler cuz Garoppolo how
many games is grappler started yeah
that's true that's true so I can't yeah
if you go dollars in contracts obviously
drop lows up there yeah but Matthew
Stafford is a stud that's what I don't
understand
Matthew Stafford and Marcus Mariota have
the same rating that just seems a little
crazy to me yeah look I think Mariota
and you're right I will give credit as
you know I I'm very tough on the Eagles
yeah because I used to kick our ass when
I play for the Giants for all those
years I had to hear it weird yeah it's a
weird relationship for you but when
should definitely I mean he was gonna be
the MVP that year if yes if he doesn't
get hurt I'm guessing there the injury
thing if you what have you done for me
lately Madden is what it is you wanna
hear something wild to the three
quarterbacks that are on the Washington
football team Alex Smith Case Keenum
and Dwayne Haskins all have a higher
rating than Eli that's crazy I think
that yeah that's some disrespect you
love Eli so much I'm a fan now what are
you gonna do guys I know I'm more than
just what people perceive of him you're
gonna defend Eli for me right now I've
been doing quarterback rankings for
random thing
how good they are at grilling how they
would finish if they were doing like a
manhunt I have put Eli like last in
everything
what is Eli do really well off the field
and if I were to make a list of every
quarterback in the NFL starting he would
be number one
work ethic oh man I wanted like beer
drinking oh I guarantee you I can drink
okay I had him I had him second or less
okay that's bad because I told Tyler I
said hey look we got to do this choke
challenge because I think I'm the best
beer chubbier in the NFL what a lineman
wise David Bakhtiari that's my guy
yes Dave will vouch for me in this you
believe this is gonna go big I can feel
it you believe you're the best beer
chucker the NFL yeah I haven't lost two
I haven't lost Dave I definitely lose to
Dave who else has done it Carl long if
you believe you're the best Pierre
drunker in the NFL and I believe a lot
of people think it's Bakhtiari
would you look at that camera I don't
you say David bakhtiari I challenge you
to a chug off and I'm the best beer
truck with the NFL dad are we at david
bakhtiari he's my boy - we've been -
we've been around the world together you
know you know what it is when it comes
to drinking a beer you know I got your
number even though his was very
impressive
you're the best left tackle in football
my friend but I think you might be the
second best beer chugger we need to
figure this out so this means though
that you're gonna need to put out a
video I'll put one out okay I didn't
want to do it because I didn't want to
like be that guy everyone was hopping on
the trash yes yes yes so I said the
caller said heading to the bottle cap
the bottle cap challenge or anything
like I say Carla we have to do a beer
drinking thing because you know Roger
for biscuit yeah
Howard doesn't drink beer so collar
automatically can't be in your Deezy oh
no I had him very low very low okay yeah
no I didn't just gun to your head if you
had you have a chug a beer who's
showering the fastest yeah you don't
think you I can put down a beer oh no I
know he can I just like putting Eli on
the bottom of the rankings it's just my
it's my little brother
you think whence is a good beer chugger
I had Wentz very average I people got
upset because he's from North Dakota
yeah
I had Wentz as my number-one griller
know my number three griller breeze was
my number one griller
Stafford's my number two like I did
really deep research like I saw Case
Keenum and Tahoe for that tournament
yeah and I was like yeah man I haven't I
had you as my number four griller he
goes I saw that he goes you had me he
goes you found a picture for my
Instagram like five years ago I go I do
a lot of research for dumb [ __ ] Case
Keenum it's amazing yeah but isn't what
does wendkos rank I give me super
religious he's very religious but I also
think some it was like whole it was like
the the wine the blood of Christ he'd
crushed that he'd be number she'd be the
number one Eva the number one a lot of
Chrysler remembering words and
Corinthians like Carson Wentz but no
Carson Wentz because Carson Wentz could
hunt a deer and like a fresh deer so
he's like who you want if you're on an
island he's number one he he was my
number one hunger know what's the Hunger
Games yeah my number one Hunger Games
guy cuz he's gonna like make a perch in
a tree and then like paint his whole
face like predator style I will give you
that if I had to do Hunger Games I would
put yes yeah cuz he's kind of slow and
he's like also gonna try and be friendly
to who else
give me some Oreo dough was my worst in
Hunger Games really yeah Hawaiian like
David I just told him the islands yeah
but I don't think he would I think he's
too nice too nice
yeah yeah I wanna hurt Mariota was my
number one stepdad rankings like a a
quarterback of the other came your
stepdad Marcus Mariota would be number
one he'd be incredible he'd take you to
Hawaii you know and anybody'd also be
super respectful to mom which is very
important that's the biggest thing
coming from a guy who's had a stepdad
Kyle Brant we had from good morning
football on and he was like it's very
important that they're like a nice guy
that's why Mario's mom and Fitzpatrick
was too you know I mean stepfather or
stepdad yeah he might get you into
Harvard that and he's like super
friendly and stuff and like he's seen a
lot of things he might crack open a
Coors Banquet beer and like slide it to
you under the table go don't tell your
mom you know I mean like you'd be really
good at it you put a lot of thought into
this too much too much so Eli I was
gonna do like quarterback most likely to
catch a fly in his mouth because I knew
I would be good at that too are you
basing that off in the face face
face Manning face what are you so on
back to the financial stuff because I
guess I didn't realize how well versed
you are in this like of a 53-man roster
how many of them do you think like know
what a 401k is and like are really
preparing for life after football in an
intelligent way right now out of the
53-man roster I want to say I won't take
it to 65 because we're gonna include
practice squad and this there's not a
lot of guys it's not a lot and I'll be
the first I was one of those guys I had
no idea I mean there's probably if guys
in the locker have a question about 401k
there's one probably three or four guys
the reps on the team that know what what
have any answers for any man how many of
them do you think are being taught well
by their agents even less than that I
mean that's no-knock to the agents
whatsoever an agent has 10 15 20 guys
yeah you can't beat luckily for me my
agent has been you know it's my guy and
we've developed a relationship that he's
all decisions I make I always give him a
call Andy Ross select Sports Group shout
out shout out the best but um it's very
it's sad it's a sad time when you seem I
don't I don't put it just on the players
I think sometimes a lot of like a lot of
times people want to say oh they're dumb
most people don't know what to do with
their finances I'm dumb like I think I'm
really done I think I'm a smart guy you
know what makes me smart I know I'm not
smart this is why I find the guys that
are smart and that's who I call when I
have questions that makes sense
and if we can do more of that because
the one thing that does I wish we could
just change the perception guys aren't
idiots they're smarter in the sense they
they know how to take care of their
business yeah we talk to each other we
try to help each other out the most we
can but we're also trying to make sure
we keep our jobs so football has to come
first house has to come first and then
other things fall on line so got a lot
of times guys because they're on the
fringe they're barely making the team
they have no time for anything else you
don't have guaranteed contracts I'm
lucky enough that I've had guarantees
throughout my career so I can in the off
seasons I'm not I'm obviously working
very hard to be what I do and to remain
but I have a time to think about what if
what do I want to do after the game and
I think more guys have to because
when you get done you've had no work
experience it's it's a cold world is it
is it a little scary I've heard you say
that not twice where it's like you don't
have a work experience yeah
is that scary to think about it ending
and kind of like what do i do then after
that if I had to write a resume right
now besides the NFL stuff sobs she would
get me into a lot a lot of yeses and
open a lot of doors true work experience
went to Syracuse University obviously
one of the very you know thought about
university great great academics yes
prestigious like [ __ ] hi Syracuse a lot
of dumb ass yeah I'd have to put down
box-boy out of Delhi and I worked for I
worked at doing like popcorn at bar
mitzvahs like I would serve popcorn I
like bar mitzvahs that's my two things I
worked at ups when I was in Syracuse
yeah like two sat in the office at a UPS
for four weeks man that's my only work
experience so it's a little scary it's
very scary I mean it's it you go into
some of these the the director of player
development down in Miami
Caleb Thornhill okay started this thing
called athlete transition University
involved this is cool I've never heard
about this before he invited one guy
from every team so out of my last year
New York I get this box in my locker
this is just a key in it and it has like
this phrase on and I didn't know who it
was from yeah but it was it's basically
said you're gonna be hearing from us
soon
didn't even know how it got on my locker
who connected me so I got a call from
this guy Caleb and he's like hey look
we're gonna be in New York in March I'm
getting two or three guys from every
team guys I think would be good fit for
this we're gonna meet CEO of rock nation
we're gonna meet all these entrepreneurs
owner of the Atlanta Falcons not enough
Falcons Atlanta Hawks the basketball
team Jesse Esler he's like his wife
started Spanx yes they kill it he's the
man so he came and spoke to us we have I
think it's Jay browning the CEO of rock
nation came and spoke with us we had
just guys from all different real estate
finance everything come and speak with
us and be like hey what interests you
what could you see yourself doing you
have the access now where you can pick
up a phone and call a CEO he's like oh
wow I'll return this guy's call he's
yeah NFL player start using it now start
leveraging did you start doing that I
did I did I started I didn't call him
you know
call Jessie its Laramie hey guy get a
job yeah but I started just finding out
what makes these people successful what
have they done throughout their lives
what do I have interest in and real
estate has been one of those things that
I love so finding you know I've been
looking at multi-family homes I'm trying
to buy something here about yeah but
learning as much as I can and when I go
into some of those meetings they're
speaking Chinese I have no idea what
they're saying right so you just keep
going back and back until you learn how
to say a few words and kind of get by
yeah and just be a fly on the wall and
then try to try to to get how you can
why do you think they picked you of all
the Giants so it ended up coming a
friend of mine or an acquaintance that I
had met now is a really good friend of
mine my lawyer in New York he met Kayla
music hey I met Justin Pugh kid is
unbelievable yeah myself a liar cities
yeah exactly I said thanks for that
[ __ ] but he's like yeah he has she
kind of has it together he's kind of
thinking of what could possibly be next
and wants to help out yes that's that's
how it got connected some word-of-mouth
just being a being a good person outside
of the the facility I feel like it's the
first thing is kind of admitting that
it's okay than it's scary that when it's
over you know what I mean like because
Eric Morgan was like one of the guys and
he's just retire today and you know he
wants to get into these opportunities
owns which the government like
designates these areas that are in bad
shape yeah and he wants to go into some
of these areas and help give back and do
some impact funding man medomak ensue
was it was there he was another guy
that's we all you know he's at him and
Warren buffer like best friends yes from
his side of Nebraska yeah it's a little
bit of an advantage right there yeah you
have a private smartest investor of all
time at your disposal man but it's it's
just fascinating to me because everyone
thinks that these guys are living the
life that you guys are just walking into
mansions with models and that chocolate
milk is coming out of a water fountain
and that you come home and each of you
has the LeBron personal trainer and a
personal nutritionist and a personal
dietitian and any time you guys get hurt
or you guys get in trouble why don't you
have a butler and why don't you have a
driver and all these things and it's it
they don't realize the truth
let me give you my truth right now so I
have a house in Arizona it's awesome
it's under construction right now I'm
doing some things that's like people
like oh that's bougie yeah I moved to
New York for six weeks to come back I
wanted to do this you know come meet
with some of the real estate yeah see my
family I'm living in a shoe box right
now 41st and 10th Avenue Wow
I hear honking at all hours at night so
I sleep with earbuds in do you know how
to get blackout shades I take the subway
every day to the gym to work out well
down in Tribeca so I'm not living like
this lavish lifestyle right now I'm I
think that's this the biggest
misconception yeah and a lot of guys are
doing the same thing I'm doing they're
just regular guys I'll get stopped every
once in a while oh you didn't used to
play for the Giants why are you on the
subway well because I'm not gonna wait
seven hours in an uber to get down here
that makes more sense the subway by the
way is hell that's what hell is
oh that's the humid waiting through the
two train three train whatever Caden in
New York during the worst time of the
year you cane in New York
when everyone leaves on the weekends and
that like it's a thousand degrees
because the concrete and the cars and
the sidewalks like I live in a fifth
floor walk-up
it's like 1887 brick yeah so literally
all that he just rises to my apartment
and if I don't have the a/c going at all
times I will bake in that place but I
was on the subway today and this is the
time for people that don't live in New
York where people are so hot and
bothered that fights happen on the
subway often and there was a guy on the
subway today that was I want to say he
was kids ofrenda cuz he was like yelling
to himself yeah
but then other people in the subway
started yelling at him and I'm like
you're gonna yell at the yelling guy on
the train like I did the thing where I
went in between the cars yeah on a
moving train got out yeah cuz I was like
ah cuz you never know I cannot allow
myself to be in a situation with
uncontrollable people when I can I can
avoid it if I can walk away in New York
like people in New York especially if
you're visiting they'll see people like
fighting on the street and they'll
either record it or they're gonna just
watch it get the [ __ ] out of Hondros and
I don't want to be near any like oh I
need to see it really there's like a
other people here and what the
experience get me out of here areas I
don't want to be anywhere near you
people they're jackhammer and there
should be a law you can't jackhammer it
or honk I gotta talk to GM or Chevy or
Ford or somebody you live to the whole
ridiculous it was all nice and calm
there's no honking on 14th Street in
Hoboken ya know this is miserable I live
in Manhattan - I know all about it
but what if they like downtown a little
bit more I'm somehow for some reason I
decided square square great idea yeah
but a Syracuse guy actually owns the
building oh so yeah that's the reason I
did it was a good rent it was the path
of least resistance yes
no I'm kind of downtown - and let me
just say another tip about New York if
you're gonna live near a firehouse
live on the firehouse block I live a
block and a half away and that's what
they're allowed to turn their sirens on
the honking the honking should be
illegal it should only be for emergency
purposes like you have to prove like you
were in Tremont like dramatic situations
yeah no no it's good I've had hockey for
a minute straight before can I ask you a
serious question there's a football one
yeah when the steroid thing had with
Patrick Peterson
I will openly admit that I texted
Patrick Peterson and I said hey man I'll
know what the [ __ ] happened but I hope
you're good I know you're gonna battle
back bubbeleh
I don't know what happened whatever as a
teammate what is it like when you hear
that a teammate that's being levied
against them um it happens in our league
and a lot of times when I first heard I
thought it was it was came out I was
like a band stump says so a substance so
I thought maybe it was like adderall or
because normally that's what it is guys
taking adderall and and really I don't
think that's a the biggest performance
in him yeah but yeah that's a whole
nother a whole another fight I mean it
had your performance I really thought
that that's what it was and I'm never
I'm not like knocking a guy for taking a
tour right and I don't know what
happened in Patrick's case and I don't
know what goes on in his life yeah he
deals a lot of different things and he
was going through a tough time last year
so you can do nothing but support your
teammate because at the end of the day
that guy's coming back to work that
guy's gonna show up week six ready to go
that guy is one of the best
cornerbacks in the NFL yeah we need him
so if I would never guys mess up guys
screw up all the time
imagine if someone followed you around
with a camera in like one time you
messed up you probably get a personal
conduct policy first I just had Edelman
on here you know and and I you know
there were certain things I wasn't
allowed to ask ya you know what I mean
because it's steroid just tough because
as an athlete there's this notion of the
short lifespan of your athletic career
but also this purity to it and when it
gets questioned you get questioned the
rest of your life yeah you're the truth
is out there I probably take steroids
once I'm done playing football you think
so yeah I got to lose a couple pounds my
heart's been working double overtime
since I was like 16 what are you a right
now well for my strength coach is
watching I'm under I'm under my way in
at 310 let's talk about weight in the
NFL for a sec okay I know this is your
show but I've got a subject know a lot
of them you get fined every week so
every Friday we weigh-in you have to
report at a certain weight so I have to
be between 305 and 310 I'm 308 point
seven today okay so I'm good I'm ready
to roll
you get fined more if you weigh 692
dollars per pound we get fined that
remember to come up it's like a
percentage of the salary whatever it is
so 600 so if you ate 311 692 if you
weighed 304 I mean it'll give us back
any money for being under oh so you
don't go live under only over Wow over
so you remember we had Damon Harrison
yes on the job yes
he was constantly having like try to cut
weight on like Thursday night before so
there's be like sauna and steam room
parties guys trying all that group of
guys trying to just Nick name stacks you
know you got a I felt like snacks would
have cut them a check for like 16 times
692 and just say I might be overweight
this year yeah 100% I think I think that
happens sometimes dude you can only cut
so much weight yeah you could only cut
like five pounds or ten pounds of water
weight depending on how much you say
your 308 point seven yeah if you stopped
playing I gotta get to like 260 that's
what you think you'd be I hope in my
head like I have this dilute there's two
wages it's gonna go
I'm not staying at 300 so I'm either
getting down I'm gonna look like Chris
need a video like Dave deals like
written
yeah or I'm gonna be very very heavy and
I can't I can't I can't I can't go that
route no I don't think your body is
naturally that heavy yeah you're right
how much are you like having to eat to
get up to 300 eight point seven so I do
I actually was a little over so when I
go down the shore I start eating Tony
boloney's pizza yeah I start to balloon
up a little bit Primo's hoagie there's a
lot of things that get me in trouble so
I actually had a drop a few pounds I
drop like four pounds so I'm not eating
as much but in season I'll do like a
thousand calorie shake in the morning
I'm doing breakfast that I'm doing lunch
you know it's forget exactly I'd have to
I had a chef so I did that one lifestyle
thing but I had it for one year my
contract year I got the chef what you
think he was one changer game-changer
but I can't I couldn't I couldn't how
much does a chef cost for a year 70 Wow
but it helps you get that contract so
you think about it 74 what I got yeah it
makes sense I haven't done it since so
that's another let me just think about
that number everybody out there used to
be able to write that off you can't
write that off and I know drum killer
yeah he took away deductions and
training this is like a very adult
podcast we used to be able to write off
training yeah I can give you like you
know I can help give the real look at
the NFL oh come on realist you know what
else you got oh no I died right off your
agent a little bit I I'd never did yeah
I moved to Florida to save on state
income tax we're still gonna see if that
works out cuz the NFL you can only save
money on bonus money so my I had a ten
million dollar signing bonus so I moved
to Florida yeah I thought I was coming
back to the Giants so I thought was
making eleven something percent I'm like
I'll save 1.1 million dollars by moving
to Florida fee yeah that's incredible
and then I go to Arizona which is four
and a half percent so right now I'm
trying to they're gonna audit me I moved
to Florida literally moved to Florida
got a license I have a Florida license
devoted I voted in Florida this past
year signed up for a church I go to
yeah and then so we'll say we're gonna
see it we're gonna see if how that works
with the with the IRS so like so
Arizona's four and a half percent what
was in New York New York's crazy yet so
I don't know if you remember when Jeter
got caught with the
tax thing I don't look at Leo Messi look
at the soccer players that get call for
tax fraud they try to claim residency in
other states to have a lower tax bracket
and they got caught so Jeter I think
Jeter didn't win his case so Jeter had
to pay the money to the state of New
York Wow
so I'm trying to win the money from from
me from Arizona which would be now do
they were off like 450,000 man on my
signing bonus
you're in you're everywhere and then you
get taxed where you play so when we play
in California I pay California state
income tax for that that week right so
when you hate playing in California
California worse than New York they're
both dishes bad California is the worst
really Western Richburg I play with in
New York signed a bigger deal than me
and for a San Francisco and he'll make
less depending out and he'll make less
money just because of the taxes and he's
got eight home games yeah plus he's got
to he's got the Rams twice yeah and the
man so Weston signed for three million
more than me something for 48 which I
don't know what his rating is Wes's my
guy he hasn't do social media so he'll
never see this but I text him right away
I said you may have signed for more but
I'll earn more that's incredible he is
he's a 70 overall so that means you beat
him you were a 72 and a very good player
country boy man well I enjoyed having
you on as always I know the 33% last
time you came on they were like me up
use the [ __ ] man
Pew's offs I call it like I see it I'm
your I'm your average guy yeah you like
that I like that I like to check out
Tony boloney's you're involved with
those guys now yeah guys come on I I'm
trying to try to think of the next but I
appreciate you kind of opening up a
little bit about like the paychecks and
all that stuff because when I hear like
a world football player a soccer player
sign a deal and they go he's gonna be
getting two hundred and twenty two
thousand dollars a week and I'm like
holy [ __ ] yeah but the fact that you
guys go through like if that's probably
why the playoffs are so big for you guys
to I ups you don't make anything though
you be like 25,000 rank it's great for
the guys that you're Eli Manning like
he's not meet that check is practice one
that's huge for those guys oh man you
but I appreciate that because it's it's
a side of the NFL that we don't often
get to see and I think that we all
assume like I thought you guys got paid
fifty two weeks a year
yeah like are the benefits could
benefits are great benefits 401 k's
two-to-one but the fact that you don't
get post career money until three years
and three games yeah you don't receive
benefits until you get three years
that's four years yeah the average life
spends three yeah and that's you have to
be active for those games so if you're
just like active for that you're not
part of the active 46 on active 53 if
you're just practice squad practice Wow
guys don't get any benefit so you don't
accrue a season when did you like a
growth spurt like were you always big
yeah it was they're lucky I was always
big but I never worked out and I got to
college really who were like lifting
weights for anyone they called me puny
like my nickname was puny to him yeah I
did five reps at 225 when I got this
Eric use so your advice then for the
young people out there that maybe
haven't gotten that big yet or they just
they love the game of football like what
would you what would you say kind of
fighters out there because I remember
when you came out of Syracuse you were
the the good feet guy what would you say
to the feet are still good yeah I know
but what would you say the guys out
there that maybe aren't the Coletti
assemblies are the Zach Barnes that are
[ __ ] enormous yeah there's a totem
pole in our game you don't have to be at
the top but just find out where you're
at on the tour that's why I get in a
fight every every offseason I find out
where I'm at in the locker room I find
out where I'm at in that totem pole and
no matter what you're doing you just got
to find out where you're at you you
don't have to like your role you just
have to know your role and that's when
my strength coaches told me so just find
out where you're at and just keep
fighting like I don't care if you're the
biggest baddest man in the NFL I'm gonna
find out where I stack up if you beat me
I probably won't fight you perfect place
to end
are you two so you haven't had a fight
yet this offseason I did I did what yeah
boom in a scuffle more was a scuffle
there was no hands thrown who was it we
sounded attack all Darius feel on from
the stairs pile on yeah yeah from the
chargers they got a little handsy yeah
we get a little handsy but I'm the type
of guy that will fight you and then I'll
sit down have lunch with you
I'm like I think I had that like fighter
mentality were like the UFC guys don't
beat
crap out of each other and then they'll
have a chip here some guys get like
sensitive what about like a Chandler
Jones now I actually try I think means
you know maybe try to fight once in
college but Chandler's not he's not a
fighter that's right you guys went to
the same school uh you have 12 Suggs on
your team now yeah
what if Ste sizzle gets in your grill
poof I don't think I don't think it will
I don't think it'll get to that I'm
inside so I deal with the D tackles I
don't think any one of me they get mad
at me when I go out and start hitting
the defensive end I'm at left guard now
so I told Chandler I'm on your side now
you can know where I'm here
Lewis a like but if you look up like T
sizzles like snarling and they moved him
inside on the pass rush in the third
down I'm not worried about it I mean
like he's an unbelievable player but
like if it has to happen and he beats me
up all right I'm just not gonna pick a
fight with him next time I probably
still will cuz I'm just a guy got a hard
head I love it you got to find out where
you're at in totem pole appreciate you
bro 33% hit him up on social what do you
do social yeah what's your to interact
Justin it's just at Justin pew or ugh he
ugh not pw8 the church pew and then
Instagram it's just a few on a 67 on
there slide into his DM I get more I get
hit up more for to say yes to the dress
than you for football I wanted to say
yes to a dress my sister it's ridiculous
and it's all like in Brazil I'll get
like just brutal I get a whole lot
Justin me llamo s I love that alright
hit him up on social let them know that
you appreciate him pew you're the man I
wish you an incredible year of health I
hope that you guys shocked the [ __ ]
League and that you're in a lot of
highlights of Tyler running around the
end with your hand in the air just go
[ __ ] Road bong-gun cars run awesome
appreciate you brother we'll be back
coming up this Thursday it's gonna be
Travis Kelce and Rob Riggle little
Chiefs episode for you we'll see you
guys then
[Music]